the FBI spent a long time trying to
track down ghilane Maxwell the British
socialite accused of being Geoffrey
Epstein's accomplice a judge in New York
has ruled it's too risky to let her go
again her request for bail refused the
prosecution claims she was an extreme
flight risk
experienced at hiding with every
incentive to flee the 58 year old is
charged with helping to recruit groom
and abuse three teenagers in the 1990s
one anonymous woman Jane Doe told the
court without ghilane Maxwell Jeffrey
Epstein wouldn't have done what he did
she was in charge I know what she's done
I know how many lives she's ruined
another accuser Annie farmer said she
was a sexual predator who abused me and
countless other victims she's never
shown any remorse she's lied under oath
and tormented her survivors she's
demonstrated contempt for our legal
system by perjury the prosecution claims
she posed as a journalist called Jane
Marshall - when she tried to buy this
house where she was eventually arrested
Maxwell's defense team proposed a five
million dollar bond they said she was an
innocent woman who would surrender her
travel documents and be subject to GPS
tracking but the judge Allison Nathan
said that she had substantial
international ties and extraordinary
financial resources that prevented her
from granting that a trial date has been
set for July next year one lawyer for
six women says she is still concerned
about any meaningful outcomes from this
case where do you see this case going
after all these years my clients are
very skeptical that the criminal justice
system is going to do anything to bring
anybody to justice for the crimes that
were committed against them because it
has let them down over and over again in
2018 when Jeffrey Epstein got a
sweetheart deal in 2019 when he wasn't
watched carefully and so he took his own
life to escape justice Dewayne Maxwell
pleaded not guilty to the six charges
against her but she is confined to a
jail and
locked into a judicial process one
decades in the making